this ain't Arby's but we got the meats
[Music]
hey what's up it's toy and welcome to
making it big the show where I take your
favorite foods and turn it into Giant
Foods for this season we are actually
filming everything with a VR camera so
if you notice that my table is a little
warped that's why you can watch the full
VR episode with a meta Quest 2 in mega
tasty that's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon worlds or on metal Quest
TV so today I have a special guest that
you all know and love I'm here hello
hello
you guys it is Ria queen of tasty I
gotta admit I'm kind of nervous oh why
you are challenging me because your
taste is expansive and I don't know what
you are going to be challenging me to
because you're kind of unpredictable
well you know I have a show called make
it fancy but you might be surprised when
I chose it's okay let's see
Korean cheese dog yeah far from fancy
it's a street food I'm new to Korean
cheese stock yeah but I love it so I
just want to eat more and why not make
it big so I came why not right what is
your favorite part about the Korean
cheese dog you know I'm a tasty producer
and we love good cheese balls yeah so I
expect you to do great cheese ball that
stretches from this here to here I don't
think I can do it but I believe in you I
think you can do that good luck friend
thank you
[Music]
let's get to work
so I have five pounds of ground beef
over here
this is a pound and a half of ground
pork belly I'm gonna mix this up
oh hey okay well tiny toys here and it
looks like she got some to say so let's
hear it no way
that long
according to tiny toy the corn dog got
really popular in Korea in 1980. in the
1980s but it wasn't until 2016 where it
gained its popularity because they like
basically rebranded the corn dog and
added like the sugar and the cheese and
all the sauces and now it's literally
everywhere in the world
so for flavoring I have I think this is
onion powder no this is onion powder
this is garlic powder this is white
pepper
oh
don't breathe that white pepper in this
is paprika and this right here is pink
curing salt so what pink hearing salt is
it's just salt and sodium nitrate
all right
I like to feel it kind of like squeeze
through my fingers I'm gonna make sure
that every inch of this meat is covered
with flavor
oh this meat smells seasoned now I am
ready to make this into a paste because
we're making a hot dog here
look at our beautiful paste
okay that was only one batch I have
this much left to do so be right back
this is not a hot dog casing because we
can't find any that's actually this big
so this is like a
um a casing for salami
here we go
[Music]
what I gotta do is really make sure
that there are no air bubbles
I don't want any air bubbles that's the
enemy
so we've already tied the other end I'm
going to
[Music]
this is my foot long Glizzy
and this is going into the oven for an
hour and a half at 300 degrees this is
going to cook the hot dog and let it
firm up so be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our boiled hot dog
I'm gonna cut this side so you can see
it
children look away
[Music]
okay so I actually need to put this in
the oven at 500 for 15 minutes because I
want this to crisp up get a nice color
going because I think he's great but he
could be better
so let's make it better
[Music]
my meat is done
it smells incredible now
we get to shave the cheese
nice and tight
[Music]
what we're gonna do is put this stick
through the dog because this is going to
hold the cheese and the dog together but
it's also like the stick to hold the
whole thing together when you're eating
it here we go
we're through I am going to actually use
these little skewers to secure
um this to this because it's so big I
can't trust just one stick you know
um so I am going to secure it with these
sticks right here
all right now time to put this together
I
oh
I need some help
[Music]
[Music]
time for the batter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hey welcome back okay let's hear it
so according to tiny toy the difference
between a Korean corn dog and a
traditional American corn dog is that
the batter for American corn dogs have
cornmeal but the Korean one does not so
that's why there's no cornmeal in this
corn dog batter the more you know
[Music]
it's game time so I have to get the
Glizzy coated in flour and then I'm
gonna bring it over here and batter it
and then coat it in panko
[Music]
a little Glizzy ASMR
the tingles
[Music]
okay welcome to the back kitchen over
there is my fry team hi Friday
fried
all right drop the Glizzy
[Music]
this Glizzy is glorious it's looking
beautiful
yay are you here I am here
[Music]
you made a box too yeah well I did a
makeup
Make It Rain
are you ready yeah three two one we love
good cheese balls
[Applause]
whoa It's a lot of cheese it's pouring
no it's pulling
[Music]
we love good cheese ball foreign
[Music]
I was going to say should we put the
toppings on
okay so I'm gonna do a cross
it's very precious cargo there's a
Sriracha shortage oh my God can we
Cheers Cheers
Chester tray
oh it's yummy it's so good I actually
really enjoyed this in the comments
below let me know what I should make big
next time
peace see ya
[Music]